Lead is a good time to get thermography,
and it is a viable substitute for a mammography.
So mammographies are obviously x-rays of your breasts
to diagnose any irregularities and lesions
that then would require getting a biopsy
and to test for possible cancer.
Thermography is a heat-sensitive instrument.
So is thermography a viable substitute for mammography?
In my opinion, yes, but they are testing different things.
So you're gonna see different things
in an x-ray of the breast versus thermography of the breast.
I think thermography is best used for screening.
Thermography is not a diagnostic tool.
So you can't use it for diagnostic
to nor can you really use mammography
for diagnostic in the case of cancer.
So the only way to diagnose cancer is with a biopsy.
Thermography is gonna be much more sensitive to the mammography.
You're gonna, you're going to catch things earlier
and that's been the biggest complaint
in the medical field with thermography.
Your, your diagnoses things to early,
first of all incorrect, thermography is a diagnosing,
but it is giving you an idea that there's something wrong.
So if you have a regular thermography
which I think if you're getting annual thermographies,
if everything is clean up with thermography,
thermographies are read by radiologists,
medical radiologists, so it's not something that is like,
it's not something that should even be considered like alternative.
So I am not a fan of annual mammographies
that radiation that you're putting in your breast
on an annual basis could be cancer-causing to itself.
There's no negatives of a thermography.
It's taking a thermal picture.
So there's zero in base of this on a thermography.
So it's really like a perfect screening tool.
So, but it is just a screening tool.
So you use that and let's say something is positive on there
then maybe you'll check that more regularly.
Maybe you'll run two marker tests.
Maybe you'll go to get an ultrasound done.
It will pinpoint different things
that maybe you want to look at and move forward with.
So what is a good time to do a thermography?
When you're healthy, it's a really good time
to get it done in a thermography.
Should everybody be doing a thermography?
Yes, everybody should be doing a thermography.
For sure, is thermography, this isn't the question,
but is thermography misused?
Why I think any test can be misused?
I had a male once committed to,
I had prostate cancer, but I had a thermography that didn't show up.
It's not going to show up on thermography.
So if thermography is going to show more surface things,
I know, I'm licensed in thermography certified
but that doesn't mean I necessarily agree
that you're going to be able to see abdominal issues
clearly with thermography.
There's better tests to use.
Thermography is great for surface things.
Thermography could be helpful for aeropathy.
Thermography could be helpful for a lot of things,
but just like any test, like any blood test, anything else,
a test is to give you clues as a diagnostician,
to give you clues.
Say, oh, well, there's something going on here.
We need to dig a little bit deeper.
We need to correlate that with other objective
and subjective findings and subjective and objective tests
in order to move forward with our working diagnosis.
So part of being a good clinician is you're doing
what's called differential diagnosis
to come to a conclusion to a working diagnosis.
And they'll say in medicine that you come to a final diagnosis,
but in truth, in practice, everything is a working diagnosis.
So that's what you use thermography and blood tests
and CTs and MRIs and everything,
to give you a working diagnosis to decide
how you're going to move forward in a treatment plan.
And then what you do through that treatment plan
is you retest to make sure that you've actually
accomplished something in through that working diagnosis.
So this is what I see as a failure in our medical field today.
So often do I talk to people that had blood tests done
that abnormalities of that blood test.
And it's like, what did your doctor do?
Nothing.
He didn't even talk to me about it.
OK, you have anemia on this blood test
that you had last September.
He never did another blood test.
I mean, this is just criminal.
So he never even told the person that they had anemia.
In order to even start a treatment procedure,
why do you do the blood test in the first place?
If you're not using that test to move towards a working diagnosis
or give you clues that you should do other diagnostic procedures
in order to help the patient.
And then when you make the clinical decision
to help the patient, then you rerun the tests
that gave you that indication of what was abnormal
is to see if you've actually collected it.
I think this is pretty color-intensical,
but it seems like we've lost color-intense in this country
in a lot of what happened to us so.